[Music]
welcome to another exciting episode a
Kos and today
yo this statue that I'm about to talk
about I have been seeking this statue Oh
I mean as long as I've been on ebay I've
been stalking this statute this statute
has been $800 has been $1200 is when
$600 has been five I had one guy out in
Philly that I was supposed to get this
statue from and I was going to drive out
there you know to get the statue from
the guy we had set everything up who's
gonna you know do the drop off through
the pickup you know I had the box to
ship a box everything it didn't happen
the guy flaked on me at the last minute
so also you know I look on the Facebook
forum groups you know so that way that
you know we can get these statues
problem you need to stuff going again no
help nothing at all I want to give a
shout out to Leto concepción one of the
guys in our many Statute rupes that's on
the Facebook forum groups and he helped
me tremendously
in achieving my goal with this statue no
it didn't have to ship a box no it
didn't have the art box but he had the
statue and he had it at the price that I
needed and this was right before
quarantine and everything started to
happen so allow me to introduce to you
oh gee
old blue eyes that ever-loving thing
Premium Format from Sideshow
Collectibles I wanted this statue
forever and thank you so much leader for
helping me achieve that goal now let's
get into the reason why I love this
statue so much see back in the days
Marvel used to have this comic book
called Marvel 201 and it used to feature
the thing most of the time he was a team
up with your favorite superheroes
you know sometimes spider-man sometimes
you know Thor whoever it was a fun read
see he's one-fourth of the Fantastic
Four
he's a strong man you know and a lot of
times he's fighting the Hulk so I was
already introduced to the thing long
before I have many things statues so
this is just one I'm gonna give you the
story on why I wanted this one right
here now the thing is not a muscular you
know character he's just how would you
say he's like a bulldog you know he's he
stout he's he's big he's strong he can
press a hundred tons so he always gives
the Hulk a run for his money but the one
thing that indeed me to this character
was in Marvel two-in-one annual number
seven the champion of the universe came
to the planet and he had like his
promoter going to different how would
you say it like S Class Heroes S Class
Heroes is what I called the super class
the strongest of the strong that has
like the Hulk name or Thor Sasquatch
Colossus
those are all the heroes that he went to
and he also went to the thing the
champion a universe said that he would
fight all the strongest heroes and I
think something was supposed to befall
the planet if he won because he will go
across the galaxy fighting all of the
heroes now remember the champion of the
universe is an elder he's the elder of
the universe okay
strong well versed in all fighting
Styles his claim to fame is no one can
last two rounds with him just two rounds
so they gave each fighter trainer and it
will teach them to get ready it was
insight I build up like a heavyweight
fight I love that annual so much because
it showed you exactly who each character
was now the Hulk was at that time Banner
was in control well they were sharing
control but if he's slipping that too
angry the whole persona would take over
so right before the fight started the
Hulk
ripped off the gloves and tried to jump
at him at the champion and the champion
was like I'm not even gonna waste my
time with you you know savage right but
then he fought Colossus dented his
organic skin he fought Thor not though
out he beat one demand of Naxos wash out
Namor didn't participate Namor left's
that he was too high and mighty to fight
the champion in the universe so it was
just left to the thing to fight him and
I love Raging Bull I love the movie
Raging Bull and in that movie Jake
LaMotta versus a Sugar Ray Robinson he
was getting beated beat and battered all
around the ring and all he could say to
Sugar Ray Robinson was could knock me
down ray he couldn't knock me down
being a fight aficionado being a amateur
boxer this comic book it meant a lot to
me so the thing is fighting him he's the
last one there and for the first round
he's getting beat all over the place but
he makes it to the second round and he
gets into the second round and he just
let it go for broke
he's just gonna start going out of
hidden hitting the champion in the body
broke some ribs but then the champion
just started to overwhelm him and he
dropped the thing and it was about to
call a fight and the thing is battered
and bloodied and he said it's not over I
don't give up I didn't yield the fight
can continue the champion helped him to
his feet and said that he's a credit to
his race that he was the reason why
there was a draw and they gave me a
different admiration for the thing so
now let's get to the statute this
statute comes in three pieces it comes
in the base the body and the head it's
amazing it's heavy it's it's just the
thing it's just rocks it's different
colors that's not just one color and you
can see in between the into the black
that's inside it just like a Jack Kirby
book and if you look at his eyes his
eyes look like little marbles and look
it looks perfect
this statue is so perfect to me and I am
so happy that you know Leto parted ways
with it well this is the part of the
video what I'm gonna ask you to like
follow and subscribe and also hit the
join button hit that join button you
know what our button is that button is
right down at the bottom so do us a
favor
hit that joint button and then you can
see all the videos that we have in the
realm also go to Lords of gaming dinette
where we have a ton of opinion pieces
you can see ok os statue episodes iron
Lords podcasts which I'm a part of
Sundays at 1:00 p.m. you can watch old
videos there and also you can watch the
best damn destiny podcasts
in the business with low kognito and
Evon tests with the last word if you're
not watching that I don't know what
y'all doing
because right now destiny is going off
the charts
this is the never ending game and I play
it all the time
so go to Lourdes gave them that net we
can get the dimensions of the Statue
became more particular to the statue
get the artist of the statue and also
stick around watch the video we go
listen to some good music and look at
the statue more in depth and I'll see
you next week
where I have another statue of my
collection that I have just dying to
show you guys stay collecting
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]